BY CAREY PRICE AND HOLDING ON.
>> Chris: HERE 90 SECONDS IN,
PIETRANGELO HAD A CHANCE.
THAT CAUGHT TO THE MASK.
A CHANCE FOR PACIORETTY.
BACK THE OTHERWAY.
DANAULT SCORES!
ARTTURI LEHKONEN.
THE CANADIENS!
AND MONTREAL IS GOING TO THE
STANLEY CUP FINAL!
[ Cheering ]
>> Chris: THE FIRST GOAL FOR
THAT LINE IN THE SERIES ENDS THE
SERIES.
ARTTURI LEHKONEN IS HERO
TONIGHT!
>> Craig: AND IT WAS AN
ABSOLUTE BEAUTY AND SO OFTEN AS
THE COACHES MEET BY THE BENCHES,
A SAVE BY CAREY PRICE OFF AN
ABSOLUTE ROCKET.
AND TRANSITION BACK THE OTHER
WAY.
A SLAP SHOT FROM MARTINEZ.
WE SHOWED HIM BEFORE.
A KNUCKLER UP HIGH.
RIGHT OFF THE SHOULDER THAT
PRICE THROUGH A CROWD ABLE TO
HANG, AND HOW ABOUT THIS PASS BY
DANAULT.
GALLAGHER THROUGH THE MIDDLE.
DANAULT ON THE OTHER SIDE.
AND LEHKONEN NO HESITATION.
QUICK RELEASE UP AND OVER LEHNER
AS HE TRIES TO GO, AND NO BIGGE
GOAL THAN THAT FOR LEHKONEN
SENDING THE MONTREAL CANADIENS
TO THE STANLEY CUP FINAL.
WHAT A RESPONSE.
THE RED SUIT CONTINUES ITS WHO
THE